what's up I'm Haley Steinfeld I'm shamik
Moore and today we are going to be
taking a quiz to find out which
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
character we are most like
[Music]
how would your best friends describe you
loyal caring driven witty honest daring
is there a select all feature just
kidding I mean I'm I'm honest and I'm
also driven
it's other things I'm gonna go with
honest I actually have a video of like
10 different people describing me and
pretty much all of them use the word
driven so nice which MCU superhero would
you call on to help in a battle Hulk
Gamora Thor Scarlet Witch shangshi black
panther it depends on the battle but but
I'm stuck between hook Scarlet Witch and
black panther I was gonna say I'm stuck
between Hulk black panther maybe Thor
Scarlet which is bad I'm gonna go with
Scarlet Witch yeah I'm gonna go with
Scarlet Witch what's your personal
weakness sweets online shopping reality
TV dining out baby animals traveling
sweets for
it's for personal weakness
um we all know it's reality TV you
should make actually no it could be
online shopping dining out because I
love to eat or traveling let's say
online shopping choose a place to take
your next vacation oh I love this
question okay Turks and Caicos talk to
me Norway Japan Tanzania Argentina
Amsterdam
y'all are making this so hard BuzzFeed
in between Turks and Caicos Japan and
Tanzania I'm gonna not do Turks and
Caicos because everybody goes to Turks
and Caicos as soon as they get a check
um
I want to go with Japan Japan that's the
most you know what that means we're
going to Japan let's go now pick a song
to play during your breakout moment
humble by Kendrick Lamar Unholy by Sam
Smith him Petras X gon give it to you by
DMX I did something bad by Taylor Swift
don't play with it by Lola Brook search
and rescue by Drake Kendrick yeah maybe
maybe I'm going with Kendrick too during
my breakout moment
yeah what are you hearing yeah gonna
give it to you
that's it gonna give it to you
humble yeah
all right cool choose a fictional
Universe to do an epic Crossover with oh
my goodness Harry Potter Game of Thrones
Riverdale power stranger things Gray's
Anatomy
definitely not Gray's Anatomy
not that I'm hey you know if you love
Gray's Anatomy amazing Gray's Anatomy
cast and success all respects I'm not
and I was necessarily going to choose it
but like it's such a good show it's such
a good show much love to Gray's Anatomy
but Game of Thrones
[Music]
I think I'll do Harry Potter lastly
choose an MCU quote for your IG caption
the hardest choices require the
strongest Wills what is grief if not
love persevering it's not about how much
we have lost it's about how much we have
left I love you 3 000 at some point we
all have to choose between what the
world wants you to be and who you are I
can't control their fear only my own you
know that whatever this whatever we
choose has to be the next caption we use
on Instagram okay I'm thinking I love
you three thousand I'm thinking I can't
control their fear only my own
word
what yes no
no yes I did I got the spot the spot
this spot just wants to be loved
[Laughter]
well that's so sick Spider-Man you crave
adventure and love to test your limits
While others settle for the boxes people
place them in you strive to live without
restrictions you're ambitious optimistic
and a little hard-headed what's that AI
algorithm BuzzFeed situation I know what
y'all want your personality matches the
spot Jonathan on like Jonathan you are
extremely confident in your talents and
abilities which means you and self-doubt
don't really mix you tend to keep a
small circle of friends because you've
had your trust broken a few times your
independent loyal and at times a little
arrogant
does that resonate with you
[Laughter]
dude thank you so much later on be sure
to take this quiz the link is in the bio
Spider-Man
verses out now it's out now go get your
tickets if you ain't get it yet
[Music]